YUFENG GUO: In this episode
of Cloud AI Adventurers,
find out how to use TensorBoard
to visualize your model
and debug problems.
Debugging problems
is a lot easier
when you can see
what the problem is.
But with gigs of training data
feeding into a complex model,
that can get complicated.
Thankfully, TensorBoard
makes this a lot easier.
Unlike traditional
programming, machine learning
can be very unpredictable.
The quality of your data, along
with the nuances of your model,
including the many parameters
that must be chosen,
all have wide ranging influences
on the success or failure
of the training process.
If only there was some way to
track some of these metrics
through the training
process, and also
look at the structure of
the model that we created,
that would enable us to
tune the model and debug
problems that we see.
Now, this abstract process
can be difficult to visualize.
But luckily, TensorFlow
has a built in solution.
Meet TensorBoard,
TensorFlow's built
in visualizer, which enables you
to do a wide range of things,
from seeing your model structure
to watching your training
progress.
TensorFlow uses the idea
of computational graphs
under the hood.
This means that
instead of adding
two numbers in the
traditional sense,
it constructs an add operator
and passes in as inputs
the values being added together.
So when we think about
TensorFlow training your model,
it's really executing
everything as part of its graph.
TensorBoard can
visualize these models,
so you can see what they look
like and, more importantly,
ensure that you've wired all
the pieces of the way you wanted
to.
Here's an example of
a more complex version
of a model graph being
visualized by TensorFlow.
Notice how TensorFlow allows
us to zoom, pan, and expand
elements to see more details.
This means that we
can look at the model
at different layers of
abstraction, which can help
reduce the visual complexity.
Moreover, TensorBoard
does more than just
show the model structure.
It can also plot the progression
of metrics on a nice graph.
Typically, we might plot things
like accuracy, loss, cross
entropy.
And depending on the
model, different metrics
can be important for you.
And TensorFlow's
Candice emitters,
they come with a set of
values pre-configured
to be shown in TensorBoard.
So that serves as a
great starting point.
TensorBoard can display
also a wide variety
of other information, including
histograms, distributions,
embeddings, as well as
the audio, pictures,
and text data that
goes with your model.
But that part's
for a future video.
For now, let's take
a look at an example
of TensorBoard with
the linear model
that we've been using so far.
First, we'll start TensorBoard
and point it to the directory
where our model structure and
checkpoint files are saved.
This will start a local
server on point port 6006.
And yes, that spells out GOOG.
We can see here some
of the scalar metrics
that are provided by default
with the linear classifier.
We can also expand and zoom
into any of these graphs.
Double clicking allows
us to zoom back out.
You can see our training
progressed nicely
with a decreasing
loss over time.
It's also clear that the
training hasn't entirely
completed, as the loss is still
decreasing at a nice rate,
even at the end of training.
So this might clue
us in that perhaps we
could run the training
process a bit longer,
and get the most out of
this training process.
Let's go over to graphs tab now.
Notice that on the surface,
the graph is pretty simple.
We're able to expand
each of these blocks
by clicking the plus
sign to see more detail.
For example, if I
expand the linear block,
we see that it's made up of
a number of sub-components.
And we can scroll
to zoom in and out,
as well as click and
drag to pan and see
other parts of the graph.
Notice also that
the names we gave
our future columns,
like flower features,
show up as named
graph components.
This can help with
debugging and identifying
how the graph is all hooked up.
Most of TensorFlow's
operations can be named.
So that's a great way
to clarify your models
and see what's going on.
Today, we learned
that machine learning
is much easier and more fun
when you can visualize the model
along with important metrics.
TensorBoard allows you
to do this with ease,
and better yet, it's
built into TensorFlow.
I'm Yufeng Guo.
And thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And remember, next time you
need to visualize your machine
learning, use
TensorBoard to see what's
happening under the hood.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you want more
machine learning action,
be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to catch future episodes
as they come out.
Also, the creators
of TensorBoard
gave this excellent talk
that the TensorFlow Dev
Summit earlier this year.
Check it out for a more
in-depth look at this tool.